l'ukrainien se tiennent fièrement autour
de cette borne ils s'adressent à leur
président
monsieur le président nous les avons
repoussés nous avons atteint la
frontière
la vidéo aurait été prise hier à la
frontière entre l'ukraine et la russie
près de kharkiv région envahie dès le
début de la guerre en dix jours la
partie colorés en bleu sur la carte a
été reprise la contre-offensive
ukrainienne a commencé fin avril dans
cette région le village de villecroze
cas comme d'autres a été en grande
partie détruits occupé pendant de
longues semaines les soldats russes sont
désormais partis le drapeau ukrainien
est de retour les habitants eux osent de
nouveau sortir des abris
les ukrainiens annonce désormais une
contre offensive en direction du zoom
dans le donbass
des renforts en provenance de l'ouest
comme sur ces images sont attendus dans
les prochains jours
et dans ce contexte de